الانفلونزا المنتشره حاليا اخطر من كورونا
ولا يبدو العالم قلقا بالقدر ذاته خلال
الايام الاسابيع الماضيه بالتاكيد لاحظ
الكثير منا انتشار حالات انفلونزا تشتاح
المدارس تصيب كبار السن ولا ينجو الشباب
من الاصابه بها ايضا اعراض هذه الانفلونزا
تظهر بشكل حمى وسعال مع صعوبه في التنفس
وغيرها من اعراض البرد وهنا منظمه الصحه
قدمت لنا خبرين الاول جيد والاخر سنعتبره
تحضيره لنبدا بالخبر الجيد جود نيوز وهو
ان نهايه كبد نايتين باتت قريبا اما الخبر
الاخر فهو ان هناك انتشارا هائل هذا العام
لفايروس خطير قد يتسبب اصابات كثيره هذا
الشتاء حول العالم يعرف باسم الفايروس
التنفس المخلوي او ار اس بي
[موسيقى]
اليوم على ما نحكي عن ار اس في هل هذا
الفايروس الي كنتو انتو كطباء وكعلماء
مختصين تحضرون منه بفتره كورونا انه الاتي
اعظم من
الفيروساتكم المهنيه حكينا انه احنا ما
نخشى انه بعد يعني الانتهاء من جائه ولا
اقول الانتهاء منكم
مازال موجوده وسيبقى معنا احنا الخوف انه
بتعرفي بعد يعني سنتين الى ثلاث سنوات من
هذا الحجر من هذا العزل من الكمامات
الابتعاد الجسدي جسمنا لم يتعرض لهذه
الفايروسات ومن اهمها اللي هو الانفلونزا
التنفس المخوي
في عندنا اصابات من انفلونزا والارز في
اكثر من المعتاد عليها وبدي اوضح اضاءه
للمشاهدين الكرام عشان ما نخوفهم لا هي مش
انه والله الفارس توحش يعني الاعراس في
ولا الانفلونزا تغيرت صار في عنا فايروسات
ممكن تؤدي الى وباء لا ليس هذا القصد
القصد انه اجسامنا لم تتعرض للانفلونزا
والارز فيه في السنوات الثلاثه السابقه
وبالتالي ممكن تكون الاعراض شوي اصعب فقط
لا غير نعم دكتور
درافت انه كرونا كان يصيب الكبار قبل
الصغار يعني كانوا شويه الصغار محصنين
اليوم لما بنحكي عن ار اس في هو يصيب
الصغار والاطفال بالدرجه الاولى كيف نفهم
ذلك 60 الارث في ليس فايروس جديده عشان بس
نعرف في الارض احنا بنعرف ومن همم يعني
مئات سنوات الارز في 60 هو فايروس يصيب
يعني بعد سنتين من عمر الطفل يكون اغلب
الاطفال قد اصيبوا في اصلا واصابته بتكون
خفيفه الى متوسطه الا الا عند الاطفال
اللي بيكون في عندهم امراض في القلب امراض
في الجهاز التنفسي او او اطفال الخداج
اللي اعمارهم قبل اوانهم اللي ممكن
يتعرضوا الى يعني مضاعفات شديده وممكن
يصيب ايضا كبار السن اكثر شيء يعني حتى
اللي عندهم يعني برده امراض مزمنه ممكن
يسبب لنا اعراض زكاميه بسيطه تذهب من
اسبوع الى اسبوعين وما في خوف ابدا منه
[موسيقى]